vous avez choisi de ne pas être mère du
tout vous avez choisi de ne pas avoir
d'enfant 1976 les femmes ont accès à la
pilule contraceptive depuis une dizaine
d'années ali vg depuis un an elle
dispose librement de leur corps est
certaine quand un choix ne pas avoir
d'enfant est ce que c'est un choix
facile à faire
non c'est un choix très difficile comme
tous les choix qui vont à contre-courant
des opinions aussi car ce choix est
vivement critiquée jugé petit medley où
se prénomme pourquoi on se serre ou du
moins devant deux enfants je trouve que
les ménages sans enfant s'est pas
valable pense à rien elle a rien dans sa
petite tête dont la société
une femme sans enfant est donc une femme
incomplète
la pression sociale est très forte et
elle est encouragée par le discours de
certains médecins il que ce sont des
femmes qui sont incomplètes ou qui ont
un arrêt sont sûrement des femmes
perturber les années passent et la femme
sans enfant intrigue toujours autant les
cataloguer jugé 1987
écoutez bien comment jacques pradel
présente son enquête nous avons eu envie
d'aller voir ses jambes curieux bizarres
étranges qui disent qu'ils affirment
devant la caméra nous n'aimons pas les
enfants nous n'en voulons pas en 1990
nous vos témoignages
on a systématiquement
ce qui est insupportable c'est la
pression sociale sur les femmes qui ne
veulent pas la voir
et voici comment la journaliste termine
les missions et le cameraman d'ailleurs
de l'équipe lors du tournage a été
tellement choquée par ces propos qu'il a
agressé verbalement donc l'une de nos
témoins on est tout à fait désolé
d'ailleurs pour elle il faudra attendre
les années 90 pour qu'enfin des hommes
qui ne veulent pas d'enfant soit eux
aussi interviewé et il faudra attendre
les années 2010 pour entendre à la télé
quelques témoignages qui change le choix
de nom désir d'enfant est un choix tout
à fait recevable et que l'on doit
pouvoir entendre en tant que
professionnels de santé sans porter le
moindre jugement dans notre société les
femmes ne se réalisent pas simplement
autour de la maternité il faut
distinguer féminité maternité
d'après l'étude aujourd'hui 6,3 pour
cent des hommes et 4,3 pour cent des
femmes n'ont pas d'enfant et ne souhaite
pas en avoir
[Musique]